Please welcome the witch-hunting, demon-slaying
brothers Sam and Dean Winchester,
Jared Padalecki and Jensen Ackles.
(audience cheering)
(intense music)
How about this way?
Yeah we'll go that way,
yeah, here we go, here we go.
Alright, we got so much to talk about.
There are so many people that are excited
to see you here tonight.
(audience cheering)
Let me begin by you guys have such great on-air chemistry
and I think it's because you are, you're terrific actors
but you're friends in real life,
you guys have been good friends for a long time.
Well, as long as the show's been around.
Okay.
Well okay, Jensen, you said once
that you would take a bullet for Jared, did you mean that?
Let me clarify, a Nerf bullet.
[Conan] A Nerf bullet.
(laughs)
Or a bullet that was being handed.
You would pass it on to him.
That's mine, that's mine.
Okay, okay.